in England a Muslim terrorist with prior
terrorism convictions goes on a rampage
at London Bridge raising a number of
questions including why he was freed
from prison in the first place in Sweden
child climate activists Greta Thun Berg
teams up with two adult leftist
activists to publish an article
admitting that environmentalism isn't
really about the environment and back
home in the good old US of a Democratic
presidential candidate Bernie Sanders
says that Christianity is on American we
examine what's really going on what all
three have in common at bottom all human
conflict is religious then Joe Biden
bites his wife's finger in a campaign
stop in Iowa on the no malarkey tour
mayor Pete says illegal immigrants
subsidize America and German Chancellor
Angela Merkel says we must get rid of
free speech in order to be free all that
and more I'm Michael Nolan this is the
Michael Nolt show
[Music]
so much to get to today and there will
be no malarkey on this show this will be
a completely malarkey free show there's
a lot happening in the news and it's all
on this central theme it's a theme that
Cardinal Manning one of the great
writers of the 19th century a great
philosopher or Catholic Cardinal he
pointed out that at bottom all human
conflict is ultimately theological all
human conflict is religious even when we
don't think it's religious even when it
looks like it's just about this
political issue or that political issue
or this taste or that taste or this
desire that desire ultimately what it
all boils down to are differences in
religion just yesterday at least 14
Christians were murdered in the African
country of Burkina Faso that was when
suspected Islamic militants attacked a
church on the first Sunday of Advent
very likely you haven't heard of that
story I'm sort of percolating a little
bit now but it's not even getting a ton
of play this is a major attack yeah we
don't know exactly who the militants
were I don't think it was radical
Methodists it would appear to be there's
a lot of jihad in that area it would
appear to be Islamic terrorists
attacking Christians not a ton of play
just a couple days earlier on London
Bridge a Muslim terrorist went on a
rampage this was on Friday he killed two
he wounded three and he did it using a
knife and a fake suicide vest wasn't a
real suicide vest he just said I've got
a suicide vest on so the nobody would
walk up to her because then he would
blow himself up this guy was eventually
beaten back by Londoners there was one
London ER with a fire extinguisher one
Lunger used a five foot long narwhal
tusks to attack him and pin the guy down
so it's pretty dramatic scene ironically
actually maybe not ironically this
attack took place at a prison
rehabilitation conference and the
perpetrator the terrorist here was part
of the programs he was considered a
success story for this terrorist
rehabilitation d radicalization program
they bring him to this this conference
show how wonderful this lenient prison
system is and then he goes on a rampage
and kills people also ironic or maybe
not the first confirmed dead was one of
the organizers of this conference and an
activist for leniency on criminals and
terrorists the other person who was
killed same thing was one of the
activists to go lenient on these
terrorists the killer the terrorist was
us maan Khan he's been a terrorist his
whole life he was a devotee of Anwar
al-awlaki who was the spiritual advisor
I suppose of al-qaeda major Islamist
figure this guy who's maan Khan had his
home raided by counterterrorism police
in 2008 he got off that time in 2010 he
was arrested for planning to bomb the
London Stock Exchange they found them
the map of the plans at this guy's house
he was given an indeterminate sentence
so they said we're gonna just put you
away until you're no longer a threat to
the public that included a minimum of
eight years this this sentence was then
changed to 16 years but in London for
these sentences I guess you get off you
can get off it very likely do after
having served only half your time so
this was eight years which was the
minimum he could have been sentenced for
what should have happened what should
have happened is the guy should have
been executed terrorists should be
executed period simple as that if you
are going to not only betray your
country or your adopted country but
target civilians for political purposes
and attempt to kill them or succeeded
killing them you should be executed for
that simple that's what we used to do
it's worked for thousands and thousands
of years very easy let's say that for
some reason in our society we don't want
to execute terrorists certainly
terrorists like this guy should be
deported the guy should have been
deported in 2010 short of that let's say
we don't want to deport them short of
that they surely should receive life in
prison right in no universe should
terrorists like this receive sentences
of eight years
this guy however got off after eight
years because of this movement in the
West to go easy on criminals and
specifically to go easy on terrorists
and specifically to go easy on Muslim
terrorists so loose Ahmad Khan was
considered a success story for this
rehab program
he ended up murdering a guy named Jack
Merritt who was leading this
rehabilitation conference that was
celebrating Khan as a success story
merit Jack Merritt who was killed wrote
his master's thesis at Cambridge on
quote a critical analysis of the over
representation of black Asians and that
means Middle East in the UK and minority
ethnic males aged 18 to 21 in the
British prison system notice that he's
writing about it from the perspective of
race black Asian minority ethnic but of
course Montcalm wasn't in prison for his
race he was in prison for his ideology
Islamism and then what his ideology
impelled him to do which was terrorism
had nothing to do with his race it had
to do with his culture had to do with
his actions and ultimately it had to do
with his religion his father the not
responded Khan's father but Jack
Merritt's father his father David wrote
this after the awful killing quote my
son Jack who was killed in this attack
would not wish his death to be used as
the pretext for more draconian sentences
or for detaining people unnecessarily
now I don't think an 8 year sentence for
a terrorist as draconian I think it's
way too lenient earlier though this his
father David Merritt had tweeted at two
years ago going to see my son in Bristol
at the weekend
he loves its diversity like most young
people do he is the future racist angry
wanks is the past she's saying if you
oppose indiscriminate mass migration if
you oppose the strong sentences for
terrorists if you oppose these things
you're a racist you're angry you're
crazy
now this ended up tragically right this
ended up tragically with his son being
killed same
the other victim Saskia Jones was
another student activist for leniency on
terrorists what are we seeing here what
we're seeing is a conflict of religious
vision not even just between
Christianity and Islam but between Islah
radical Islam rather and secular
liberalism we'll get to that in a second
first I've got to thank our friends over
and honey it is always important to use
honey when you're shopping online it is
especially important this time of you
everybody's doing a whole lot of
Christmas shopping out there you need
honey you will save I don't know
thousands of dollars I've certainly
saved thousands honey is a free browser
extension that automatically finds the
best promo codes whenever you shop
online this means you always get the
best deals without even trying on over
20,000 sites that includes Amazon eBay
Target and more honey has found over 10
million members over a billion dollars
and savings honey supports 22,000 stores
are lot more than that honey has over
10,000 five-star reviews on the google
chrome store I have used honey since
before the Daily wire existed it is soap
I couldn't tell you the last product I
used shopping with honey because I think
I just always shop with honey you know
in the old days you'd go you'd shop
online and say enter a coupon code and
then you'd say okay well I want to save
money so then you google the coupon
codes you find all these shady web sites
you try to click them they don't work
you get all these pop-ups you get it you
don't do that honey just does it all for
you automatically it takes two clicks to
install automatically you get the best
promo codes in your in that website if
you're buying gifts this holiday season
you need honey if you're not buying
gifts you certainly know someone who is
do the masala tell them about honey it
will get you the best price it's free to
use install so just two clicks get honey
for free at join honey calm slash cough
fa has that for throwback CoV fe fe that
is join honey calm / co f fa c OV e fe
fe so what are we seeing here you know
we saw the New York Times posted this
this article after the London attack
Jack Merritt died and
London Bridge attack don't forget what
he stood for which is to say don't
change your mind about criminal
sentencing for terrorists just because
this terrorist was broke at it because
of this rehabilitation program was out
of prison and then ended up killing even
the people who advocated to get him out
of prison this is a conflict of visions
we know what motivated it was Montcalm
was radical Islam what motivated the
people who let him out of prison what
motivated them was another sort of
religion secular liberalism secular
liberalism is a matter of faith and
unfortunately it is the dominant
religion of the West right now it is the
religion that took over the West after
the West gave up Christianity secular
liberalism is taken on faith the way I
could show you this is look at how the
people who defend secular liberalism
we're talking about the incident they're
saying don't ignore what happened don't
look at what happened don't look at the
results of these secular liberal
tolerant diverse if everybody forgive
everything as a matter of civil law not
not as a matter of personal law
forgiveness is very good personally but
as a matter of the actual civil law you
can't just only forgive people you need
criminal justice secular liberalism
saying no don't do that
don't look at that it's refusing to
acknowledge the facts it's refusing to
acknowledge the circumstances here
because secular liberalism has this
faith that everything could just be
rehabilitated there's no in the criminal
justice there's no such thing as justice
itself you should never have retributive
criminal justice it's all just about
rehabilitating everybody because
everybody can just be rehabilitated with
the right circumstances that isn't true
that's a religious premise and it's not
true
we know that radical Islam is a problem
in the West all right there have been
countless Islamic terrorist attacks and
terrorist plots over the past several
decades thousands and thousands of
people murdered disciples of secular
liberalism
refuse to acknowledge that here's an
example just last week a radicalized
Muslim was arrested for trying to blow
up Miami Dade College of Broward College
did you hear about that did you know
about that did you read about that in
the news probably not it's there you can
look it up but they didn't do it
a young man 23 year old Salman Rashid of
North Miami Beach tried to bomb both of
those colleges this is not being covered
because it conflicts with the narrative
of secular secular liberalism which
seeks to ignore Islam and suppress
Christianity if you want an example of
that by the way look no further than the
Democratic presidential candidate Bernie
Sanders Bernie Sanders last week was
pressing was interrogating Russell
Vaught the nominee to be deputy director
of the Office of Management and Budget
he was put up there by Trump for the
position Sanders was interrogating the
guy because he believes ultimately
Sanders believes that Christianity is
not compatible with America here's
birdie in the piece that I referred to
that you wrote for a publication called
resurgent you wrote Muslim quote Muslims
do not simply have a deficient theology
they do not know God because they have
rejected Jesus Christ his son and they
stand condemned and of Ko do you believe
do you believe that that statement is
Islamophobic absolutely not senator I'm
a Christian and I believe in a
Christians again I apologize I do
forgive me oh yeah we just don't have a
lot of time do you believe that people
in the Muslim religion stand condemned
so I give you again senator I'm a
Christian and I wrote that piece what is
that really the statement of faith we
understand that I don't know how many
Muslims there are in the Merc I really
don't know probably a couple of million
are you suggesting that all of those
people stand condemned what about Jews
they stand condemned - senator I'm a
Christian I understand you are a
Christian but this country is made up of
people who are not just I understand
that Christianity is the majority
religion but there are other people
different religions in this country and
around the world listen to how angry
Bernie gets there I understand you're a
Christian you stupid shut up you
Christian shut up you
Christian you but Bernie doesn't
understand religion because Bernie's an
atheist I know I don't know that he's
ever come out right and said that he's
an atheist but he is all but said that
he said I'm not religious I don't
practice a religion I'm not an atheist
he's prep certainly practically an
atheist and he doesn't understand
religion I mean what a stupid question
excuse me mr. vork you you say that you
don't believe that people who don't
believe in jesus are going to heaven do
you believe that that statement is
Islamophobic well first of all I don't
think anything is Islamophobic cuz it's
a completely ridiculous and made-up term
but even if he did he
unfortunately this guy bought probably
to his benefit but unfortunate for all
of us who want clarity on this issue he
should have thrown the question right
back at Bernie he should have said
senator Sanders you're asking me if I'm
if it is wrong and hateful and bigoted
for a Christian to believe that Jesus
Christ is the savior that that there's
no salvation outside the church
senator Sanders do you believe that your
question is Christ a phobic do you
believe you're asking a Christ a phobic
question that's another term that I mean
what is that what what on earth could
that turn me you don't hear that term a
lot but it would that would be a
ridiculous way to show the
ridiculousness of the point that Sanders
is making by throwing it right back on
him but you never hear that because
Bernie Sanders as an atheist is is
effectively practicing the religion of
secular liberalism and it's just not
sufficient it just doesn't work we'll
see he actually goes on he gives away
the whole game in the end we'll get to
that in a second first I've got to thank
our friends over at zip recruiter hiring
it can be a challenge we all know that
codable co-founder Gretchen Heber
experienced how challenging hiring can
be after unsuccessfully searching a new
game artist to grow with her education
tech company but then she switched a zip
recruiter obviously she immediately saw
a difference
you can too by signing up for free at
zip recruiter comm slash Knowles came to
wles zip recruiter does not depend on
candidates finding you okay it's not
just like the old job boards where you
you posted the job and then it's like
you throw a spaghetti at the wall and
you hope something sticks zip recruiter
finds the candidates for you by using
zip recruiters screening questions to
filter candidates Gretchen found it
easier to focus on the best ones then
find the right one in fact after posting
her job on zip recruiter Gretchen said
she was surprised she found with
qualified applicants so quickly she
hired a new game artist in less than two
weeks with results like that it is no
wonder that four out of five employers
who post on the zip recruiter get a
quality candidate within the first day
time is money okay it's it's very hard
to hire people so just go out there use
the best don't waste your time don't we
should really make sure you get the best
candidates zip recruiter the smartest
way to hire CY zip recruiter is
effective for businesses of all sizes
try zip recruiter for free at our web
address zip recruiter dot-com / Knowles
Canada wles that is zip recruiter comm /
Knowles Canada WL e s Bernie doesn't
understand what religion is I mean how
crazy to ask a guy hey do you believe
that if you're a Christian do you
believe that people who don't believe in
Jesus are like a little bit in trouble
you think they don't quite have it right
you think maybe there's no salvation
without the Savior say senator Sanders
do you know what religionist you if you
know what Christianity is I mean what
would he ask this question to a Muslim
what'd he say excuse me you say that
people who do not believe in Mohammed
are wrong about religion that they're
condemned that they're in trouble do you
think that that statement is a little
Christ - phobic a little Judea phobic a
little atheist - phobic no he would
never ask him that because the purpose
of this line of questioning what the
left always does in the religion of
secular liberalism is ignore Islam
suppress Christianity he he goes on and
Bernie gives away the game in your
judgment do you think that people who
are not Christians are going to be
condemned
thank you for probing on that question
as a Christian I believe that all
individuals are made in the image of God
and are worthy of dignity and respect
regardless of their religious beliefs I
believe that that as a Christian that's
how I should treat all individuals do
you think your statement that you put
into that publication they do not know
God
because they rejected Jesus Christ the
Son and they stand condemned do you
think that's respectful of other
religions I would simply say mr.
chairman that this nominee is relief not
someone who is what this country is
supposed to be about he's just look the
guy this Christian guy is not someone
who is what this country is supposed to
be about by the way Russell what it's
not like he's some total radical wacky
Christian he he just believes that you
need Jesus to be saved that's something
that all Christians believe that is the
New Testament this is the what Bernie is
saying is that Christians are right
that's not what this country is about
this country that was founded by
Puritans
who sailed on the Mayflower and
celebrated the first Thanksgiving which
we all celebrated last week this country
which had its first major speech titled
a model of Christian charity this
country who in all of its famous
orations has invoked God specifically
the Christian God as it voted in her
most famous speeches and and in our
currency there has been a movement in
the West for over a century to sideline
religion you heard Bernie Sanders just
say he said do you think that it's
respectful to other religions to have
your own religious views right what he's
saying is if you believe in Jesus that's
exclusive it's excluding other religions
if you hold any religious belief that by
definition excludes other religion same
thing with Islam same thing with Judaism
it's exclusive so he's saying is it
respectful of other religions to do that
well by that definition of respect the
only way you could respect other
religions does not believe in them at
all
that's that's what the secular left has
tried to do it doesn't work though
because man is fundamentally a religious
being it's why you're seeing young
people flock to climate activism we saw
there was an article published just just
last week by Greta Thornburg Louisa
who's the child climate activists Louisa
Newbauer who's a radical leftist german
politician and Angela Valenzuela who's
another adult leftist activist and the
column admits that that climate change
is fundamentally not about the
environment it's about so much more
it's a totalizing religion what does the
article say the article says quote the
climate crisis is not just about the
environment it is a crisis of human
rights of justice and of political will
colonial racist and patriarchal systems
of oppression have created and fuelled
it we need to dismantle them all our
political leaders can no longer shirk
their responsibilities
there was a blue checkmark guy on
Twitter who acknowledge this this guy
Zach Cantor he said quote one huge
drawback of nuclear power is that it
doesn't dismantle systems of oppression
it only produces clean energy that's the
drawback for the environmentalist is
that it only produces clean energy this
makes it unsuitable for solving the
climate crisis which isn't just about
the environment it is like this guy is
the environmentalist version of Saint
Paul right Saint Paul writes in
Ephesians our wrestling is not against
flesh and blood but against
principalities and powers against the
rulers of this world of the world of
this darkness against the spirits of
wickedness in the high places very
famous line from the Bible that's what
this guy said because the purpose of
environmentalism is not just to have a
clean environment it's so much bigger
the climate crisis is not about the
climate
it's about religion it's a religious
vision it is led by political activists
and idols rather than by scientists and
by the way I'm not pointing at the
climate change as a religion as a knock
on climate change
I mean I'm pointing it out because
there's some hypocrisy or they say it's
scientific and secular what really it is
a sort of religious vision but I'm not
attacking it as an insult right I'm not
saying it's
religious therefore that's bad I'm
pretty religious I think religious is a
very good thing I think that man is
fundamentally a religious being and I
don't even blame leftists for falling
for their religion all right at least
these people the radical climate change
people at least they're recognizing that
secular liberalism is insufficient our
humanity requires something more than
that we're longing for something more
than that
same way I feel about transgenderism
transgenderism is literally false it's
not true a man cannot become a woman by
wishing it woman can't become a man by
wishing it there are not 57 gender is it
more
it's literally false but at least what
it speaks to is this sense that human
beings have a soul we're aware that we
have a soul that we're not just matter
we're not just clumps of cells that
scientific materialism and secular
liberalism are ultimately false same
thing with climate change the world's
not going to end in 10 years because of
the sub monster that's not true but
there is a sense that there are greater
forces at work in this world it is not
the case that the patriarchy and the
this supremacy and that's the privacy
that those are systems of oppression
that are keeping us down that's not true
but there is a true sense that that
these people are intuitive that this
world is fundamentally broken that this
world is flawed that there are
principalities and powers and spiritual
wickedness in high places it's not that
this world is controlled by the
wickedness of the patriarchy or the
white supremacy or this said it's
controlled by the devil it's that that
the devil is the Prince of Lies and the
prince of this world here and that we
need some salvation it's not that
they're wrong that there will be an end
of days they're wrong then it's going to
end in ten years but there will be an
end of days and look we're entering this
Advent season right now Advent is the
period of time before Christmas when
Christians contemplate death judgment
heaven and hell it's a good reminder
that all human conflict is ultimately
theological we are going to have a
religion everybody's got to serve
somebody the question you have to ask as
an individual and as a society is what
religion are we going to have we've got
a lot more coming up but first I got to
thank our friends
it keeps this is we're talking about
very deep and weighty of important
things here today let's talk about
baldness
two out of three guys will experience
some form of male pattern baldness by
the time they're 35 that's no good but
what is the good news the good news is
with today's advancements in science
keeps offers proven treatments that can
combat the symptoms of hair loss and
help you keep the hair that you have at
half the cost of your local pharmacy
keeps us completely revolutionized the
way that men are treated for hair loss
thanks to keeps you no longer have to go
to the doctor's office for your hair
loss prescription you can now visit a
doctor online and get your hair loss
medication delivered to your home no
more waiting rooms no more pharmacy
checkout lines get doctor attention and
discreet drug delivery all from the
comfort and privacy of your own home
we're talking about these religious
visions let's not remember man is spirit
and body if you hug your body to be
healthy and look good you know
I'm not saying that I'm a great Adonis
of a man okay I'm not some hulking
decathlete one little help that I've
always had in the lady Department is
have a lot of hair nice thick head of
hair you can prevent hair loss
prevention as the key keeps treatments
really work they're up to 90 percent
effective at reducing and stopping
further hair loss the sooner you start
using keeps the more hair you'll save so
you got to act fast many men will even
experience hair regrowth with keeps
treatments find out why keeps has more
five-star reviews than any of its
competitors find out why it's got nearly
100,000 men who trust keeps for their
hair loss prevention medication keeps
treatment start at just $10 a month plus
for a limited time you can get your
first month free that is one great deal
for getting to keep your hair it's a
tremendous product if you're ready to
take action and prevent hair loss go to
keeps calm / Knowles cater wles to
receive your first month of treatment
for free that is ke e PS dot-com /
Knowles Kara wles
there is a shocking news alert today
from the Washington came out a few days
ago from the Washington Post tells you a
whole lot about 2020 and
look no further for the 2020 Democratic
chaos then pastor Pete Buddha judge Joe
Biden's biting his wife's finger and
then some really crazy stuff from Angela
Merkel which I think ties it all
together we'll get to all of that but
look before we do Friday was crazy right
it was absolutely insane if you didn't
catch it we put together a Black Friday
promotion where all of our plans over at
daily wear calm were 50% off we learned
something we learned something about our
audience you all really like coupons all
right maybe we should have been able to
predict that more of you became
subscribers on Friday in a single day
than in any given month in the history
of the daily wire then Saturday came
along our customer support team was very
busy a lot of you missed the deal on
Friday you wanted us to honor the deal
lots of current subscribers were
confused about whether or not it worked
on upgrades so so for the spirit of
Justice the spirit of mercy and the
spirit of this giving the season we're
bringing it back that is right one more
day of this magnificent promotion when
you become a subscriber to daily
wire.com today you will get 50% off when
you use the promo code DW 55 zero that's
DW 50 as an insider you'll get access to
our live shows two extra hours of bed
every day alongside many other things
when you're an insider plus you get all
of that plus the glorious leftist here's
tumblr how can you miss that with our
new tear of all access you get to chat
with me and the rest of the team here at
daily wire to clarify for current
subscribers you can use this for
upgrades so what are you waiting for get
over to daily wire.com use the promo
code DW 50 before time runs out we are
not writing any of that cyber tuesday
stuff there will not be any cyber
Tuesday I promise you that this is your
last chance go to D or put in the code
DW 50 and go to daily wire.com to get it
right now the only wire that Cobb will
be back with a lob war
all right we've got to check in on the
2020 campaign trail things are not
looking great for the left okay you
don't need to take my word for it you
can take their words for it the left
knows that that left knows that things
are not looking great for them which is
why I got that I guess it was on
Thanksgiving or Black Friday I think was
on Thanksgiving though I got a news
alert on my phone all right now then the
story was that Trump decided to spend
Thanksgiving with the troops in the
Middle East that's great what a great
thing to do it's really nice already
there had been news reports Trump is
spending the day golfing Trump is
spending the day selfishly he wasn't
really he was overseas with the troops
this was the Washington Post News Alert
that I got on my phone for no I don't
have a Washington Post app I don't
subscribe to The Washington Post this
was from the Apple News Alert quote
Trump's photo-op play facing impeachment
the president strikes strives to look
hard at work that's the story the story
is Trump spent Thanksgiving in the
Middle East but wopo says it's a
photo-op yeah it's cuz of impeachment
yeah he just wants to look like he's
working our he's not really do it he's
just looking like it don't believe your
eyes from Phillip Rucker at the
Washington Post as Democrats in Congress
pushed to impeach him Trump is toward a
manufacturing plant in Texas boasted
about economic gains and signed numerous
bills
he served turkey to US troops in
Afghanistan on Thanksgiving and grieved
with the families of fallen
servicemembers at Dover Air Force Base
in Delaware that's the story that should
be the headline but the left hates
what's going on so much because the real
headline if they had just been honest
about what they were thinking is Trump
is doing a good job and we hate that
that's the real Washington Post headline
why are they so upset the Trump is doing
a good job it's because none of their
candidates are doing well at all they're
falling apart on the campaign trail to
begin with the front-runner still the
main guy Joe Biden Joe Biden is on a bus
tour of Iowa right now called I kid you
not the know malarkey tour
Oh Joe Joe would have been better doing
the hair smelling and shoulder massage
tour I mean at least that way it
wouldn't have been so cringe inducing
isn't the no malarkey tour this is a
ripoff of John McCain's 2008 tour
might've been his 2000 tour - called the
the Straight Talk Express by the way if
you want to rip off a presidential
campaign don't rip off a two-time loser
okay they just have suggestions
Joe Biden is already a two-time loser
though he's about to be a three-time
loser it's a ripoff of John McCain
Straight Talk Express which was ironic
for McCain me as McCain was one of the
most notorious flip-floppers in US
political history and it's ironic for
biding his Biden is one of the most
prolific Liars in American political
history but it's it's stupid for another
reason obviously the word malarkey just
makes him seem like he's six thousand
years old he could call it that that the
23 skidoo tore the spirit of auditor he
might as well say I'm a really really
old guy bust or by calling a number
larkey now what Biden is trying to do is
just embrace it
right yeah have an old-fashioned guy but
that's what you need you need stable
statesmen but by even by using the word
you could call it the BS - a no BS tore
by putting the bust or in the negative
you are making that term the essence of
the campaign so no malarkey tore the
word that people remember is malarkey
it's not know so actually when I was
thinking of this today this morning if
my mind it was called the malarkey
Express tour which obviously would be
the the opposite meaning of no malarkey
tour but you just think malarkey okay
it's the malarkey Tory be like if it
were called the no BS tour what you
would think of is BS
okay this tour is about BS you don't
want to put yourself in the negative but
look that's the least of Joe Biden's
problems Joe Biden was on the campaign
trail on the no malarkey bus tour and
his wife was up there talking about what
a great guy he is and why you should
vote for her but she's waving her hand
around and Joe Biden decided to bite her
finger and one day cut to the present
the United States you call your kids in
from the other room because you want
them to hear what the President of the
United States okay this was a funny
moment you probably saw the memes going
around but as she's speaking she's
waving her hands around and Joe he's
like she's going right in front of his
face and he just leans in and kind of
nibbles on her finger a little bit this
actually could have been cute or funny
if it were a different candidate if Joe
Biden were not already being dogged with
the image that he's creepy
and he's inappropriately affectionate
and he's going senile this could have
been a really funny little moment but
because of that the guy just didn't read
the room and he goes for it and now
there's this image going around of him
like kind of feebly and confusedly
licking his wife's finger you know or
chewing on her finger doesn't look good
he's not helping himself if it's the
fact that there are always gonna be
unfair attacks in politics people are
gonna take a cute moment and turn it
into a creepy moment people are gonna
take a funny moment turn it into a
serious somber moment that's always
gonna happen the trouble is if you have
not countered that image that they're
putting out already then you're in
trouble and Joe is not countering that
image he was in Iowa giving a talk about
I don't really know what because the
talk ended up surrounding his leg hair
and the color and shape of his leg hair
I kid you know I don't really know what
he was talking about here is Joe Biden
rambling incoherent Lee for 30 seconds
and by the way you know I sit on the
stand and it get hot I got Ilana I got
hairy legs that turned that that that
that that turned blonde in the Sun and
the kids used to come up and reach in
the pool and rub my leg down so it was
trained and then watch the hair come
back up again they look at it so I
learned about roaches I learned about
kids jumping on my lap and I'd love kids
jumping on my lap if it's Saturday Night
Live Writer
turned in that script and said hey
this is gonna be our satire of Joe Biden
this week the producers would say now
that's too far that's too ridiculous
except that was actually Joe Biden
actually talking about how for some
reason on the campaign trail how he used
to be at a pool and the kids would go up
and rub his legs cuz it had kind of
weird hair on it and that's when he
learned to love kids sitting in his lap
you can't make this stuff up he appears
to be losing it okay he appears I'm not
even saying he's totally demented I'm
not saying he's I'm not I'm saying he's
lost whatever political ability he once
had Joe Biden is one of the all-time
great glad handers he's one of the
all-time great just smiling simpering
politicians who goes around and Pat's
you on the back and makes you feel like
he really likes you and he's a really
good guy
okay that's always been Joe Biden's
superpower he's losing that because he's
just not as with it as he used to be
because he's up there in ages and people
of his not just his age baby but his
wherewithal should not be running for
president so the Democrats are in
trouble there now pinning their sort of
moderate could win in the Midwest hopes
on mayor Pete Budaj edge but that isn't
gonna work because Budaj edge this whole
campaign has not been able to figure out
who he is his I think his instincts tell
him to be the Midwestern nice likeable
moderate guy okay look he's a Harvard
guy he's a Rhodes Scholar he's okay
that's the lane that he's gonna go to go
in but he keeps seeming like a radical
he keeps his Radek radicalness just
keeps peeking out you know I wonder if
this is because he's a millennial he's
younger so radicalism becomes more
naturally to young left wingers but he
keeps coming out so you see it not just
on the hectoring over you know if you
don't if you don't support radically
redefining marriage you're a bad person
in a bad Christian it's not just even in
the hill he'll say that if you don't
support abortion you could be a bad
Christian he's you tried to say that the
the Bible defends killing babies now he
was at a campaign event called the Poor
People's Campaign and
he said that illegal aliens are actually
subsidizing America I mean the
uncomfortable reality is that
undocumented folks are in many way it's
like Social Security subsidizing
everybody else and we need to talk about
that
yeah not true at all completely false
the uncomfortable reality is that is a
outright lie the Government
Accountability Office found in 1995 1995
24 years ago when the illegal
immigration problem was way way less
intense then what we're seeing right now
they found that illegal aliens in the
u.s. generate more in costs than
revenues to federal state and local
governments combined the estimates of
national net cost of illegal aliens vary
greatly ranging from 2 billion to 19
million dollars per year that's not
today that was in 1995 when we had way
fewer illegal aliens and when we had way
fewer government services available to
illegal aliens illegal immigration is a
huge net cost of the country there is no
evidence whatsoever for what people who
to judge is said but then he somehow
gets even more radical because the the
person from the poor people's campaign
who is interviewing him has the audacity
to suggest that illegal aliens are just
coming here because they're reclaiming
land that was stolen and there's peabody
judge nodding along in agreement and and
and should we have some conversation
whenever people say we call people
illegal aliens and all these things that
are not human I'm certainly not
Christian why can't we just own in
America that the some of the people that
are trying to come from Mexico here are
coming back to land we stole and the
reason we took the land is because
people wanted to keep their slaves I
mean we got it we have to have some
historical clarity around these issues
Abraham Lincoln was against the
mexican-american war we need to have
some historical clarity here which is
why and look I've never cracked a
history book open in my life
but it's why I'm just gonna say
random things that have popped into my
head for historical clarity obviously
what he's saying is not historical at
all the United States didn't steal land
from El Salvador or Nicaragua or
Guatemala which is where the majority of
these illegal aliens are coming from
these days the whole idea of we stole
the land anyway is ridiculous
because until very very recently the law
of conquest was the law of the land so
for instance very often you will hear
these kind of they're just plain old
leftist activists but sometimes they'll
pretend that there are indigenous
activists or some other subset of
leftist activism they will say we need
to return the land to the Native
Americans and I always say ok which
Native Americans are we returning it to
we stole land from the Comanche Indians
should we return it from the Comanche
Indians the Comanche Indians stole it
from the Apache Indians do we return it
to the Apache Indians who had the land
before the Apache Indians how about
further down south in Latin America
which is what these guys are talking
about do we return lamb to the Aztecs
the Aztecs were some of the most
barbaric conquerors in all of human
history they were monsters they
slaughtered 80,000 men women and
children it just the the single
consecration of the temple of
Tenochtitlan do we return it to them
I don't think so do we return land to
the Taino Indians do we return land to
the Carib Indians who attacked viciously
physically attacked him often ate the
Taino Indian we're gonna attack return
this land to a ridiculous argument but
it's not an argument based in reality
it's an argument based on these kind of
random impulses toward left ISM and
that's what mayor Pete is falling him to
he just can't resist it he's nodding
there along because he doesn't want to
contradict the guy means the Democrats
have nobody I mean who's gonna who's
gonna win it who's gonna take it now I
think Bernie maybe has more of a chance
than ever because Warren exploded
herself with her ridiculous healthcare
plan Biden is falling apart and pastor
Pete can't find his Lane who's gonna
who's going
when Mike Bloomberg I don't think my
Bloomberg is gonna win they're in
trouble and Trump is doing very well at
the moment he's got pretty decent
support he's got his base firmly in line
largely because of impeachment and he's
made huge inroads into the black vote
one poll shows he's got thirty four
point five percent of the black vote at
the moment which was wood historically
end the Democratic Party on the national
level and there are other polls that
back up his significant support among
black voters bad news for the left they
don't know how to respond to this and
around the world you see just this kind
of doubling down on the same stale old
secular liberalism that we've seen for
decades and decades for over a century
now over in Germany Angela Merkel is now
so doubling down on this she says that
we need in the name of liberalism in the
name of freedom we need to suppress free
speech I am generally skeptical of
Chancellor's of Germany okay and it's
because you know I want a little
historical clarity too just like that
guy talking our mayor Pete Buda judge
alright little if you look with a little
historical clarity we'll find out
Chancellor's of Germany not always the
best people but Angela Merkel there with
a completely straight face gives this
speech save we need to stop free speech
in the name of freedom I'll translate
from the German she says we have freedom
of expression in our country for all
those who claim that they can no longer
express their opinion I say this to them
if you expressed a pronounced opinion
you must live with the fact that you
will be contradicted expressing an
opinion does not come at zero cost okay
fair enough then she goes on but freedom
of expression has its limits those
limits begin where hatred is spread they
begin where the dignity of other people
is violating this house will and must
oppose extreme speech otherwise our
society will know
you'll be the free society that it was
unless we get rid of freedom of
expression we won't have any freedom
look the freedom that matters most is
the freedom of expression right man is a
ultimately a religious animal and the
way that our society expresses itself is
through politics how do we engage in
politics through speech speech separates
us from the beasts we have this ability
to communicate with each other if you
radically restrict that you are
restricting our humanity in our freedom
but the question is what kind of freedom
are we talking about what kind of
freedom is Angela Merkel talking about
there are many types of freedom freedom
from material want that's what socialism
promises it never delivers but that's
what it promises that's what capitalism
promises and it does deliver that's one
type of freedom there's freedom from
discomfort that's what the safe space is
promised although it's pretty they're
pretty uncomfortable for the people who
they're censoring there's freedom from
censorship then there is a deeper kind
of freedom and exalted freedom the
traditional understanding of freedom in
the West which is the Christian
understanding which is freedom from sin
it's freedom from this kind of
wickedness you know Christ says he who
sins is a slave to sin this is why just
that very shallow understanding of
freedom that freedom is not having other
people tell you what to do which is
important we don't want other people to
tell us what to do but that's
insufficient that secular liberalism is
insufficient ultimately because we can
enslave ourselves to addictions to drugs
to porn to any of our appetites we can
do that and this is why the wisest
ancient societies all the way through
the present have understood that freedom
comes from pursuing the good it comes
from virtue
it comes from self-discipline that
discipline will be imposed on you or it
will be imposed by it will be imposed by
you rather on yourself or it will be
imposed by a massive tyrannical
government but that will that the order
will stand the discipline will have to
be there that is not merely a political
question what that boils down to
ultimately is a religious question and
what we have
to acknowledge what we have to decide is
which religion we are going to follow
because everybody's got to serve
somebody that's our show
I'm Michael knows as the Michael Doyle
show come back tomorrow and we'll do it
all again the Michael Noel's show is
produced by Rebecca dabka wits and
directed by Mike joiner executive
producer Jeremy boy senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis clever and our technical producer
is Austin Stephens assistant director
pavel why douse key edited by danny
D'Amico audio is mixed by my core amina
hair and makeup is by Jessa alvera and
our production assistant is Nick Sheehan
the Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19 on
the Matt Walsh oh we're not just
discussing politics we're talking
culture faith family all of the things
that are really important to you so come
join the conversation
you